Hello everyone, it's
Gio again, giving
you my second lecture
for psychiatry.
Today we're going
to be talking about
schizophrenia and
psychotic disorders.
Before we begin, I'd
also like to thank
Dr. Corey Dyson
out in Arkansas for
helping me put this
presentation together.
Before we jump into
it, let's quickly
go over the session
objectives. We're
going to really
focus on the DSM-5
criteria for all
the disorders that
we're going to be
talking about today,
mainly schizophrenia
and other psychotic
disorders. We're
also going to try and
describe briefly the
etiology and epidemiology
of all of them, as
well as differentiate
between primary
psychotic disorders
and secondary psychotic
disorders. Last
but not least, we're
going to want to
describe some of the
treatments and evidence
-based assessments
for each of these.
So one quick note
before we start, if you
guys watched my last
lecture, you already
know this, but anytime
you see this blue
star, try to dial
in and really focus
on what's being talked
about there. You do
not need to memorize
every single thing
in this PowerPoint.
That would be crazy.
The whole goal of
this is really to
understand the overall
clinical picture,
not just memorizing
all the details and
the buzzwords. So try
your best with that.
So before we get
started with the rest of
the lecture, let's take
a quick look at this
clinical case. So
our patient's name is
Gene. It's a 25-year
-old male that presents
to the ED with the
chief complaint of being
poisoned by his
girlfriend and mother.
When you enter the room,
he's been pacing but
he stops upon you
entering you notice that
before you can introduce
yourself his lips
are softly moving as
if speaking to himself
he steps back when
you extend your hand
to shake as you
introduce yourself and he
provides brief abrupt
short answers after
varying latency
sometimes short sometimes
longer at times he
appears distracted and
you need to then repeat
some of your questions
he also looks around
the room periodically
as if distracted or
looking for someone
or something else
when you inquire about
his past psychiatric
hospitalizations gene
mumbles something
under his breath about
hating those shots and
the horrible nurses and
when you ask for
clarification he simply
says never mind and
refuses to answer any
more questions he
minimizes the concern about
being poisoned and
then asks if he could
go smoke *********
now he begins to pace
again and begins to
look more agitated it.
Taking a look at the
ED chart, you have
no next of kin,
and it's unknown if
the patient was
living with someone or
alone. Also has no
past medical history.
Limited physical
exam due to limited
cooperation from the
patient as well. In terms
of vitals, he's a
febrile, pulse is a
little on the high side
at 90, blood pressure
is significantly
elevated, and respiratory
rate is on the upper
limit of normal.
He's also agitated,
making little to
no eye contact.
Lungs were clear to
auscultation, cardio
exam was fine,
abdomen was
soft, currently
appears disheveled,
this is just a
stock image that
I found online,
as well as being
poorly groomed
and having poor
hygiene, and he
has little to
no eye contact.
Urine tox is
positive for THC, but
there is no alcohol,
as well as no
poison or any other
drugs of note.
When Gene's mom and
girlfriend then show
up, they note that
he's been hospitalized
a total of three
times throughout his
life, and he was
prescribed olanzapine,
but he stopped taking
it about three months
ago. He has then
struggled with his
mental health, starting
at 21 years of age.
Recently, he has
noted hearing voices
that tell him to,
quote, do bad things.
So let's take a step
back, and you guys
can pause here to
think about it for a
second. What are the
key points that we
can take away from
this patient history?
If you guys were doing
a question on UWorld
or any sort of test
bank, or this was
on your comps. What
would you pick out
from this patient
history if this
was a big vignette
in order to
point you in the
right direction?
Okay, so I hope you
guys had a chance
to pause if you'd
like to. And
some of the key
points that we need
to take a look at
are as follows.
He appears to be
entertaining an
internal dialogue
that only he is
able to interact
with or respond to
there was also
notable flat affect
he also appears to
be distracted looking
around searching for
someone or something
multiple previous
hospitalizations with
shots thc positive
on the urine talks
there was a lack of
eye contact during
the encounter
looking down looking
around the room it's
also noted as having
hallucinations and
delusions, okay? And what
could this entail,
right? He's believing
that his loved ones
poisoned him as well as
hearing voices, right?
So loved ones poisoning
him could be a delusion
and then hearing
voices could be an
auditory hallucination.
And last but not
least, he was
prescribed an
antipsychotic
and stopped taking
it recently.
So what do we know
about making any type
of psychiatric
diagnosis? Well, before
we jump into it, we
first need to rule
out all other non
-psychiatric causes,
right? We had to do
the same thing in the
previous lecture
with those cases when
we talked about
depression and bipolar
disorders. So what
else could present with
this constellation
of symptoms, right?
Potentially,
there's some sort
of dementia,
maybe Niemann-Pick
disease, a Lewy
body disease,
even early-onset
Parkinson's disease in
young patients that have
a genetic predisposition
to it will initially
present with
psychotic symptoms mimicking
schizophrenia could
be some sort of toxin
or substance use that
wasn't picked up on
the urine tox there's
a bunch of different
things that could be
causing this but we
need to rule out all of
these before we
immediately jump to that
psychiatric diagnosis
all right and this is
just repeating what
i said we must always
rule out other medical
conditions first before
we go and make a
psychiatric diagnosis.
Okay, and just for
posterity, let's put
this differential
diagnosis for the
psychiatric causes here,
right? So it could be
some sort of substance
use disorder, it
could be a schizophrenia
or psychotic
disorder, it could
even be a depressive
disorder or a bipolar
disorder that presents
with psychotic
features, right? So many
different things to
consider when we're
trying to narrow down
our differential.
Well, the first thing
we need to do is run
a couple different
labs. We want to get
a good CBC and CMP. We
want to see that all
of the metabolic
markers that we normally
are going to check
are doing well, right?
We want to make
sure that nothing is
elevated, that there
are no abnormal vital
signs, that there's
no indications for any
sort of cancer or
any infective process
that could be causing
this constellation of
symptoms. So question
two, in our preliminary
lab results, we
find that everything
is unremarkable. The
patient then begins
yelling and threatening
to hit anyone who
gets close to him and
******* on the walls.
What do we
want to do now?
And has our
differential changed?
Okay, so here are
a couple of the
different things that
we could do for this
patient right now.
First is admission
to a psychiatric
hospital, right? So
we might want to
possibly initiate a 72
-hour hold if they're
unwilling to go
to the hospital on
a voluntary basis.
And it's up to the
clinician, the psychiatrist
at the hospital in
order to determine
whether or not the
patient is a danger to
themselves or others,
and if they'd benefit
from the 72-hour hold.
We can also try verbal
de-escalation, right?
Using communication
strategies to calm the
patient, help reduce
agitation, but this
could also backfire.
it might make
the patient more
confrontational. They
might not be able to be
de-escalated, in
which case we always
want to have a backup
plan, okay? Very
unassuming, non
-threatening posture, but
also close to the
exit of the room if we
need to escape in
a hurry, all right?
Another thing that
we can think about is
medical intervention,
so we can use some sort
of sedative. They
used to use some drug
cocktails in the past,
but now we're recommending
im injection of
ziprazadone or geodine
is the name brand for
it ziprazadone is a
second generation
antipsychotic in the past
you might hear people
using haldol sometimes
haldol still used in
an emergency department
for aggressive
patients but really in
the psychiatry field
we want to try and use
ziprazadone now
instead simply for the
fact that these drug
cocktails could potentially
sedate the patient
for upwards of 24
hours with the ziprazadone
we're going to be
able to get in there
and start to help them
once their aggression
is minimized. And
last but not least,
if you were thinking
restraint and seclusion,
this used to be done
in the past, but it
really is no longer
recommended. We can set
up one-to-ones with a
nurse or like a CNA,
a certified nursing
assistant, if we do have
available personnel.
All right, with all
of that out the way,
let's jump into talking
about what a lot of you
guys were probably
thinking when we read
that patient uh vignette
and we're going to
talk about schizophrenia
now so according to
the dsm-5 in order to
diagnose schizophrenia
we need greater than or
equal to two symptoms
from the following
list at least one of
those symptoms must
be a psychotic symptom
and psychotic symptoms
have the little asterisks
next to them those
would be delusions
hallucinations and
disorganized speech these
must also be present
for at least six months
greater than or equal
to one month of active
symptoms. So what
does that mean? If we
have one week of symptoms
separated by three
months, and then another
week of symptoms,
and then another three
months, that would
not constitute a diagnosis
of schizophrenia.
You must have at
least or equal to or
greater than one month
of active symptoms.
The other symptoms
on this list, grossly
disorganized or catatonic
behavior, and negative
symptoms, while not
psychotic symptoms,
we can have either
of these paired with
either delusion,
hallucination,
disorganized speech,
or maybe even multiple.
Now, another term you
guys might have heard
in the past, either
through MCAT or previous
psychology classes or
lectures, is positive
and negative symptoms.
So what exactly
does that mean, right?
In psychology and
psychiatry, positive
basically means the addition
of something that
wasn't there before. It
doesn't mean that it's
a good thing per se,
okay? In this
case, delusions,
hallucinations, and
disorganized speech count
as positive, right?
Delusions and
hallucinations, some
of the patient's
senses could be
playing tricks on them,
adding in stimuli
that really isn't
there in the real
world, right? So
that's kind of
what we think of as
positive, the
addition of something.
Conversely, negative
is going to mean that
we take something away,
right? So this would
mean we take away
emotion from speaking, we
get flattened affect.
Maybe there's just
reduced speech overall,
right? Or maybe there's
a lack of initiative
and agency on the
patient's part. They have
no motivation, right?
Now, let's dive in a
little deeper into all
of these psychotic
symptoms, right? A delusion,
simply a fixed false
belief. In this case
with gene he believes
that his family
poisoned him okay
hallucinations are
just perceptions
without external
stimuli and it could
be any sensory modality
in this case hearing
voices okay last but
not least we have
disorganized speech which
is simply the loosening
of different associations
derailment or
incoherence and what
does that mean basically
think of very similar
to your flight of ideas
that we talked about
with bipolar disorder
except instead of
jumping between multiple
different topics this
is kind of coming out
as a word salad with no
tangential trajectory
for the conversation
or whatever topic that
person is trying to
get across it's just
completely disorganized
now a quick note on
hallucinations we talked
about how they can
affect any sensation
but let's talk about the
most common and least
common ones that you're
most likely to encounter
at a patient with
schizophrenia auditory
and visual hallucinations
are the two most
common auditory being
the first visual being
the second olfactory
hallucinations are
pretty uncommon for
schizophrenia but they are
more common in temporal
lobe epilepsy so
that can help you to
distinguish the two
types of pathology in any
sort of question stem
additionally there are
tactile hallucinations
which are typical of
******* and amphetamine
use, as well as alcohol
withdrawal. An example
of this would be
like feeling bugs are
crawling on your skin.
Meanwhile, somatic
hallucinations involve
a sensation from within
the body, and they
are pretty obvious
if they're bizarre.
A good example of that
is Ekbom syndrome,
also known as delusional
parasitosis. So
basically what that
is, is just a fixed
false belief that the
patient is infested with
parasites okay um and
then lastly we have
gustatory uh which
are going to be
hallucinations from the
sense of taste and those
are exceedingly rare
in schizophrenia
all right let's also
talk a little bit about
different types of
delusions that any
patient could experience
with schizophrenia.
So as a reminder,
delusions are false,
non-culturally
sanctioned beliefs
that are held
with conviction,
even in the face of
overwhelming evidence
to the contrary. And
this last part is key.
So let's talk
about some of them.
First, we have
persecutory or paranoid
delusions, which
are most common in
schizophrenia or
delusional disorders.
The belief that the
person is being pursued,
stalked, framed, or
tricked is key for
classifying this as a
persecutory or paranoid
delusion. Then there
are ideas of reference,
thinking that
things like the news
or the paper are talking
about or to them.
Then there's grandiose
delusions, believing
that some agency
has taken control of
their thoughts,
feelings, and behaviors.
Next, there's somatic
delusions. Part of the
body is feeling like
it has been diseased
or is malfunctioning
in some particular way.
Then there's nihilism,
which is an exaggerated
belief in the futility
of everything,
okay?
Next, we have
delusions of love.
This also used to be
called erotomania, in
which patients feel
loved by another person,
often of a higher
status, who is merely
just an innocent
bystander. This could be
a boss at work, This
could be a celebrity.
This could be a
crush that doesn't
even know that the
patient exists, right?
Those all constitute
delusions of love.
Then there's
delusions of jealousy.
This one's pretty
simple, suspecting
someone of being
unfaithful, all right? And
then last but not
least, this one's my
favorite. This is
called delusions of
doubles, and I actually
got to see this in
the hospital, which
was kind of surreal.
But basically,
delusions of doubles is
also known as Capgras
syndrome. and it
describes when a patient
believes that a family
member or a close
friend has been an
identically appearing double
so as if they've been
replaced by a cyborg
or an alien that
looks just like them i
think of like the scrolls
if you know marvel
or any other type of
sci-fi medium in which
humans are slowly
replaced with um with body
doubles right this is
also more common in
dementias but it can
still be seen as a
delusion within schizophrenia
itself next let's
talk a little bit about
disorganized speech
which is just odd
bizarre behavior such as
smiling laughing
inappropriately responding
to internal stimuli etc
and often more often
than not it's purposeless
and this ambivalent
behavior or movements
might also be
accompanied by random
intermittent agitation
this might also encompass
things like having
a disheveled attire
unusual inappropriate
attire etc as well as
disjointed speech patterns
and different behaviors
that are going to
reflect disorganized
thinking this could be
perseveration tangential
speech word salad
and the use of
neologisms neologisms are
just making up new words
or slang often combining
or creating different
words together
think about like brunch
which is brunch and
lunch or blending words
which is just smog
right um maybe even
shortening words like turning
mathematics into math
and perseveration
is basically just
repeating the same things
over and over and over
again involuntarily
repeating the same
words repeating
the same phrases
things of that nature
next we're going to
talk a little bit
about catatonia which
is categorized by the
presence of greater
than or equal to three
of the following 12
symptoms of marked
motor disturbances.
So when we're talking
about catatonia,
we're specifically
talking about motor
disturbances and motor
symptoms, all right?
So let's jump into it
and let's talk a
little bit about each.
Stupor is very simple.
It's just not actively
relating to the
environment at all. Think
about just that loafy
day that you have on
the couch where you
really just kind of veg
out and forget about
the outside world that
would be stupor right but
this is to a debilitating
effect then there's
cataplexy which is
just sudden temporary
loss of muscle control
um can be triggered
by strong emotions as
well like laughter
surprise or anger there
might also be waxy
flexibility which is simply
just when people's
limbs remain in whatever
position they're placed
in especially when
they're moved there
by someone else think
about it like posturing
a doll or an action
figure Then there's
mutism, which is self
-explanatory, no or very
little verbal response.
Negativism, which
is simply the
opposition or having
no response to given
instructions from
some sort of outside
stimulus or
healthcare provider.
posturing which is just
spontaneous and active
maintenance of a
posture against gravity
so this is different
from waxy flexibility
because posturing
happens of the patient's
own volition or it
might not be of their
own volition and it
might be something
randomly that happens
but the point is that
they are not placed
in this position by
someone else they do
it on their own then
there's mannerism
which is just odd uh
caricatures of normal
actions like peculiar
ways of dressing or
performing everyday tasks
that might differ
from the status quo.
Then we have
stereotyping, which is
just repetitive,
abnormally frequent,
non-goal-directed
movements, kind of like
motor tics that you
might experience in
Tourette's syndrome.
Then there's
agitation, but specifically
agitation that is
not influenced by
any external stimuli.
Grimacing, which is
excessive frowning or
teeth bearing. Then
there's ecolalia, which
is mimicking another's
speech. Not to be
confused with echoproxia,
which is mimicking
another's movements.
So quick thing to
note, do you need to
memorize each and every
single aspect? No.
But in a setting where
you're given a clinical
vignette or some
sort of question that
you need to answer,
being able to identify
these different
aspects of catatonia
might help to get you to
the correct answer a
little bit quicker.
Now, let's talk
about a couple of the
negative symptoms of
schizophrenia, right?
We've talked about
blunted or flat affect
before, but there's
also a lochia, which
is just poverty of
speech, inability to
speak as much, or
having a limited number
of words that you're
able to utilize.
There's asociality,
which is simply
social withdrawal,
right? So if
sociality is someone
who likes to be social,
asociality is
social withdrawal.
There's anhedonia,
which is a lack
of interest in doing
the things that
you used to enjoy.
Remember, we saw
this with the
depression lecture.
Ambivalence, an
inability or extreme
difficulty to make any
decisions in general.
And then avolition,
again, a lack of interest
or engagement in goal
-directed behavior,
right? So lots of A's,
a-logia, a-sociality,
anhedonia,
ambivalence,
a-volition. So
that's how you
look at all of
these negative
symptoms, okay?
As we were talking
about before, these
can easily be confused
with some depressive
symptoms and or
side effects of
antipsychotics or maybe
even cognitive symptoms
in those with dementia
or Alzheimer's.
However, these are
just as troubling or
disabling to the
patient as the positive
symptoms, so we don't
want to miss these.
okay now let's talk a
little bit about the
treatment that we use
for schizophrenia so
this is often going
to involve the use of
antipsychotics we have
two main classes your
first generation
fgas and your second
generation sgas
these second generation
antipsychotics
are more commonly
used as they have
much lower risks of
severe side effects
right what could these
be like neuroleptic
malignant syndrome nms
which is defined as an
elevated temperature
muscle rigidity irregular
pulse tachycardia
tachypnea altered
mental status the works
all right basically is
a full autonomic nervous
system dysfunction
and this could be
lethal if antipsychotic
is not stopped and
supportive care is not
given and this has to
tie into the mechanism
of action of a lot of
these antipsychotic
medications which
directly modulate
neurotransmitters in the
body then there's also
tardive dyskinesia which
is a chronic neurological
syndrome caused by
antipsychotic use
it's defined by these
repetitive involuntary
movements including
grimacing eye blinking
and other involuntary
movements more often
than not tardive
dyskinesia is permanent.
So if we are noticing
negative side effects
of our antipsychotics,
we need to discontinue
that drug as soon
as we identify them.
So let's take a quick
break and answer
a quick question. True
or false, onset of
schizophrenia in
childhood traditionally
has worse outcomes.
Here I'll give you
guys a second to
pause if you'd like.
And here's the answer.
This is true. So the
typical onset of
schizophrenia really is
early to mid-20s for
males and by late 20s for
females. And in total,
it affects about 1%
of the global population.
Again, you don't
need to know that
percentage specifically,
but this is just to
kind of give you a good
overall idea of how
prevalent schizophrenia
is. So some other factors
that could indicate
worse outcomes
include poor premorbid
functioning childhood
onset family history of
schizophrenia abnormal
brain imaging an insidious
onset as well as
concomitant drug *****
now let's take
a step back and
let's look at
delusional disorder
to clear up
some potential
confusion as a
lot of people do
tend to mix and
match delusional
disorders and
schizophrenia
disorders together.
And so really what we
need to think about
with delusional disorder
is that in contrast
to schizophrenia,
this is defined by
one or more delusions
that last greater
than or equal to one
month with no other
prominent psychotic
symptoms, right? So
there's no hallucinations,
there's no disorganized
speech, nada.
It's just the delusion
that's there, okay?
If there are any
hallucinations, they're
usually extremely
mild. And really the
core feature is this
presence of a well
-systematized and
encapsulated delusional
belief. So let's
think about this for
a second. Let's say
I give you an example
of a 55-year-old
man who for the past
five years has been
thinking that his
neighbor is stealing
his trash constantly.
No matter
what evidence is
proposed to the contrary,
he constantly thinks
my neighbor is
stealing my trash.
They're stealing my
trash. They're a thief.
They're a bad person.
And it's lasted,
again, greater than
or equal to one month.
There's only this
one delusion. There
could be more, but
there's no other
hallucinations or
disorganized speech. That
would be a delusional
disorder. And due to
the nature of this,
it is exceedingly
difficult to treat.
With that out the way,
let's jump now into
schizophreniform and
brief psychotic disorder.
So the way I want
you to think about
this is on a timeline
and i got this from
dirty medicine he is
phenomenal for high yield
videos on youtube
if you guys are into
that but basically
what we need to look at
first is the time
frame that is the b big
like key takeaway from
all of this okay so we
go from one month
then to six months and
then greater than six
months for our timeline
brief psychotic
disorder is defined as
having one positive
symptom that lasts between
one day and one month.
Usually it could
be stress-related. So
following the death
of a loved one, maybe
an extremely stressful
encounter could lead to
these brief psychotic
disorders. Again,
no more than one
month. Once we pass
that one month mark, now
we're in the territory
of schizophreniform.
Now, schizophreniform
has two symptoms
that last one to
six months. However,
impaired functioning
usually is not
required for diagnosis,
okay? And that
is in contrast to
schizophrenia, okay?
And then we talked
about schizophrenia
before. It needs to
be greater than or
equal to six months
prior to the diagnosis,
and you have to
have greater than or
equal to one month
of active symptoms
during that period.
So to recap, brief
psychotic disorder, no
more than one month.
Schizophreniform
disorder,
up to six months.
Past that six-month
period, now we're
looking at schizophrenia.
All right, and again,
I want you guys
to think about
this as being a
continuum of duration
and impact. So
this is another
summarized little
graphic that you
guys can use, right?
Brief psychotic
disorder, remember, with
this sudden onset,
short-lived break
from reality, usually
there's a full recovery,
and antipsychotics
can be curative,
okay? With
schizophreniform disorder,
the prognosis is a
little bit worse, right?
You have intermediate
stages, uncertain
prognosis, and this
can also be treated
with antipsychotics
as well, right? And
it's about one-third
to fully recover.
Most individuals
that present with
schizophreniform
disorder are usually
diagnosed much
later on with
schizophrenia and to cap it
all on remember
schizophrenia is as chronic
debilitating functionally
impairing illness
so let us go ahead
and take a quick
look at this right
so one of the key
differences between
brief psychotic disorder
and schizophrenia
i'll give you
guys a quick second
to think about this
and hopefully you
guys had a chance to
think and this would be
b and c only so really
we're not worried
about whether or not
brief psychotic
disorder only involves
delusions and and not
hallucinations right
because you can still
have some potential
hallucinations albeit
mild right the main
thing key differences
that we're talking
about is time frame
and duration one
month versus your
greater than six months,
as well as the fact
that schizophrenia
includes positive and
negative symptoms,
whereas brief psychotic
disorder only includes
positive symptoms.
So that's a pretty
key thing that you
want to clue into here.
All right, let's talk
a little bit about
some of these risk
factors, genetic risk,
just because it's
interesting. A lot of
this stuff is not really
going to be tested
for you guys. This
is more or less just
for patient education
when you guys get
into the hospital. We
still don't definitively
know what causes
schizophrenia. There
is a pretty big theory
that schizophrenia
is due to an excess
of neurotransmitters
causing aberrant sensory
inputs. That's what
leads to these delusions,
these hallucinations.
They're receiving
signals from the
brain, even though
there's no external
stimuli to generate that,
right? So some genetic
risks would be a
family history of
schizophrenia, like
with most diseases. This
does have a genetic
component to it, either
first or second degree
relatives mainly.
Increased paternal
age is another
risk factor for
schizophrenia, right?
So as you get older,
even though your
***** are still
viable as a male,
you do have risks
for birth defects,
for mental health
disorders, things like
that. There's also
something called
velocardiofacial
syndrome, which is a
22q11 chromosomal
deletion. This is
different from DeGeorge,
but I figured I
would mention it
because it does present
with increased risk
of schizophrenia.
Here we have also
environmental causes.
So some things that
they found were
that immigrant
populations have the
highest risk for
developing schizophrenia.
Again, this is not
causative. This
is just a correlation
that they found.
There are potential
insults during
pregnancy, such
as intrauterine
infections,
particularly influenza,
have also been
correlated with
increased risk of
schizophrenia, as well
as maternal starvation.
And this is just
theorized to be during
the maternal period,
if the baby does not
get the proper nutrients
it needs, if the
mother doesn't get the
proper nutrients she
needs, it ends up
becoming a more risky
pregnancy, more risk
of developing schizophrenia
in the future.
So another thing is
they talk about this
two hit hypothesis
so these genes could
convey a vulnerability
um but it doesn't cause
the disease without some
sort of environmental
trigger which is
why a lot of times
people may go their
whole lives until they
get to their 20s um
and then all of a
sudden they have a snap
right or they break
down and this is really
um important to kind
of think about
because it's just like
when we think about
cancer right um you know
you could have that
two hit hypothesis
where you're fine and
then all of a sudden
you have this random
point mutation with
their what they're
talking about here right
now is that these
triggers that could happen
could be something
extremely traumatic,
something that was
really hard on the
patient's mental
health themselves, and
thus they spiral out
from there, right?
So here's another
quick clinical pearl.
How do we know whether
or not there is
another psychiatric
condition, right? So
there are some clinical
features I would
suggest secondary
psychotic illness, right?
And this is really
just a big checklist of
things that you can
look at. So let's say
you have symptoms of
delirium in an older
individual. Maybe their
first psychotic episode
happened after age 40,
which is way beyond
the initial period
that we talked about
before, right? Early
20s for males, late
20s for females. Rapid
development symptoms,
affect that's,
you know, it was
normal range, not
blunted or flat,
presence of any general
medical conditions
with any
pathophysiology that
could be capable
of altering brain
functioning, again
talking about epilepsy,
Alzheimer's,
Neiman-Pick, things
like that, as well
as evidence of
exposure to
separate sypoactive
substances, so
*******, *********,
***,
methamphetamines,
you know, any
drug that's out
there, you name
it, it can
affect cognition.
All right, so let's
change gears now and
let's talk a little bit
about schizoaffective
disorders so these are
disorders that meet
the criteria for both
a mood disorder and
schizophrenia okay and
so to differentiate
between just a regular
mood disorder um like
depression or bipolar
um we need to have
greater than or equal to
two weeks of psychotic
symptoms without any
manic or depressive
episodes right That
would make the psychotic
disorder the primary
disorder here, hence
why we have ******
followed by affective.
We can have
schizoaffective
disorder depressed type,
which remember from
our last lecture, we
talked about all
those SIG-E-CAPS
symptoms that you would
have in depression.
Or you could have
schizoaffective disorder
bipolar type, which
is when you have
psychotic symptoms that
are coupled to manic
symptoms. That's your
DIG-FAST mnemonic.
right? To treat this,
really, it's just
second-generation
antipsychotics for both
subtypes. You can add
in some antidepressants
if there is a depressed
type, as well as add
mood stabilizers for
the bipolar type. And
ECT can be used for
refractory treatment.
All right, so this is
another very important
slide just for you
and your test-taking
career whenever you're
trying to answer
psychiatry-themed
questions. And really,
test makers love,
love, love, love
to have students
differentiate between
schizoaffective disorders
major depressive
disorder with
psychotic features
and bipolar disorder with
so how are we
going to go about
figuring out
which of these disorders
could potentially
be the correct answer
right so when you
have to answer these
questions the first thing
that we're going to
do is name the primary
psychiatric disorder
while the second
part of the name is
going to be the secondary
disorder so let's take
look here right if
we look at schizoaffective
like we just
talked about right we
have psychotic symptoms
and then the secondary
disorder affected
these would be the
mood symptoms depressed
versus bipolar right
now which is the
primary or secondary
one like we talked about
before we need to look
at the question stem
carefully to see
whether or not symptoms
occur by themselves
for at least two weeks
okay so here's a quick
example if a patient
presents with psychotic
symptoms for at
least two weeks with no
concomitant depressive
symptoms, that would
mean that depressive
symptoms will come and
go. And the primary
disorder would be
schizoaffective. The
secondary disorder
then would be depressed
type. Okay, so hopefully
that makes sense.
Alrighty, moving on
with our other psychotic
disorders. First, we're
going to talk about
postpartum psychosis.
Now, this is another
one that I've actually
seen in the hospital.
it is exceedingly
rare, 0.1 to 0.2%
incidence rate, but it's
characterized by mood
-congruent delusions,
hallucinations, and
thoughts of harming the
baby or self, right?
Again, it's going to
follow delivery, hence
why it's called
postpartum. Now, some risk
factors for this
include first pregnancy,
right, family history
of any bipolar disorder,
psychotic disorders,
as well as recent
medication changes. So
in the patient that I
saw, they had no history
of any mental health
disorders. It was
their first pregnancy.
Afterward, they started
to develop delusions
and hallucinations,
as well as thoughts of
harming them themselves
and their baby. And
so they were admitted
to an inpatient unit.
And they ended up finding
that unfortunately,
she was very resistant
to different types
of treatment. So
they've been trying to
optimize the treatment
for her specifically.
And speaking of
treatments, or again,
hospitalization and
initiation of atypical
antipsychotics, the
patient that I saw actually
did go for ECT,
which seemed to help
significantly after all
of the less invasive
medication-based
treatments were completed.
All right, and the
rest of this stuff is
going to really just
be a little bit of a
bonus, hence why I don't
have the star. Well,
why am I going to
include this if we're
not going to be tested
on in this lecture?
Well, you will get this
in separate lectures
later on on personality
disorders, and
these are very
important to know. But I
wanted to include them
here for posterity
because they do kind of
get confused a lot with
regular schizophrenia,
especially in
students first studying
psychology and psychiatry.
So let's talk a
little bit about these
two personality
disorders. Schizoid and
schizotypal are type A
personality disorders.
They are not psychotic
disorders, okay?
Schizoid personality
disorder is characterized
by this profound
detachment from social
relationships and a
restricted range of
emotional expression. They
prefer social withdrawal
and solitary activities,
right? So this
is different from
avoidance personality
disorder in which
individuals are terrified of,
you know, being in
public and actively try
to get away from social
situations instead,
right, here we
have individuals
that just prefer
social withdrawal
and solitary
activities. They have
a lack of interest
in intimacy,
right, not that they
are unable to pursue
it, they just don't
care as much about it,
and they have limited
emotional expression,
right, they're pretty
indifferent to others'
opinions, and they're
rather aloof, but
again, this is a
personality disorder this is
not a psychotic disorder
okay next we have
schizotypal personality
disorder so this is
on the schizophrenia
spectrum and it may
include brief psychotic
episodes such as delusions
however these are
less frequent and less
severe than schizophrenia
which is why
schizotypal personality
disorder is a personality
disorder and not a
psychotic disorder
They may also be coupled
with an eccentric
appearance, odd beliefs
or magical thinking,
interpersonal awkwardness,
and they may like
intimacy, but they
may just find it
difficult to really find
anybody that jives with
them and their vibe
because they're pretty
quirky and they
might have those more
severe psychotic symptoms
from time to time.
So here's kind of
how I like to think
about these two,
right? So I think of
Professor Trilwany or
Doc Brown from Back
to the Future. Those
are kind of like
your schizotypal
personality disorders,
right? They're
quirky, they're weird,
you know, their
aesthetic is a little bit
odd, but relatively
harmless overall, right?
Here we have
schizoid, which I
like to think of
Dr. House from
House MD, it's
an older show,
as well as Sheldon
Cooper from Big Bang
Theory. I can't believe
to say that's old now
too. But these guys,
again, they are more
recluse, they like
their alone time, right?
And really, it's one of
those things
where, again,
just having a good idea
of these archetypes
in your head is going
to help you kind of
get to that answer in
that question stem a lot
quicker and a lot more
efficiently so just
to wrap this up schizoid
there's no interest
in relationships it's
inclusive to self
kind of a loner they
might prefer to work
nighttime jobs they don't
have to interact with
many people and
schizotypal again that
eccentric magical thinking
you can also think
of like miss frizzle
from the magic school
bus for schizotypal
um odd beliefs aloof
dressing weirdly okay so
all of these things kind
of define these two
schizoid and schizotypal
personality disorders.
And again, you'll
learn more about these
in another lecture.
So last but not least,
here's some clinical
pearls for your
psych rotation in
the future, right?
And if you're ever
dealing with a patient
that presents with
an acute psychotic
episode, or maybe they
are admitted again
after being a
frequent flyer, you
always want to look at
their teeth, as poor
dentition is quite
common in chronic
schizophrenia, right?
Schizophrenia also almost
always leads to
nicotine use,
all right? Again,
this is a correlation,
but a lot of it is
really due to needing an
escape or something
to distract themselves
from hallucinations and
delusions they might
currently be experiencing.
Now, hallucinations
in the absence of any
negative symptoms,
remember like they're
a flat affect, and
especially without
the other positive
symptoms is almost
always going to be due to
substance or a medical
cause, okay? So if you
just have an individual
coming in with
hallucinations, you
really need to do your due
diligence to investigate
and make sure
that you're getting
what you need from the
patient to make the
most accurate diagnosis.
Substance use is
also quite common in
schizophrenia, as we
talked about before. They
use it as a coping
skill to manage the
illness, whether it's
nicotine, *********,
a other type of drug
use. And then always
trust your gut, right?
So if you're ever
in a room and you
feel like a patient
is aggressive, maybe
you're trying verbal
de-escalation or
something like that, and
it is really not
working, you can always
leave the interview
room if you feel
threatened or suddenly
scared. It is perfectly
okay. It is acceptable.
And really, it
is the preferred method
of making sure that
you are safe in your
clinical practice.
All right. And so these
next couple slides
are going to be
summary slides you guys
can take a look at
these by no means are
these all inclusive
but it's a really good
way to kind of break
down the info if you
guys like to make
flash cards like anki
again another summary
slide here are some
of the references again
never neglect first
aid they have really
good summary charts
and explanations dirty
medicine is great
up-to-date if you have
that Arctos link all
really good references
for any additional
information that you
guys want to look
up or dive into and
here is the lecture and
lab feedback form so
hopefully you guys
enjoyed this lecture
hope it was informative
and have a great
rest of your semester